hi heute habe ich mir auf twitter ein
paar videos schicken lassen wo leute
sagen was sie an meiner person oder
meinem kanal stört und habe in dem video
dazu bezogen stellung genommen wollte
viel spaß dabei ja irgendwie voll viele
von euch lieben get down an sich oder
bei mir keine ahnung aber ubisoft steht
aber nur da kommt wieder geht dann war
es wieder getan
am samstag gibt es wieder gap down
zusammen mit justin das war eine richtig
krasse runde also richtig gute runde ich
hoffe mal dass ihr euch auch so gefällt
und ja es ist so schwierig das zu
treffen erst mal das lied das schreiben
mir öfters leute dass sie finden ich
sollte mir leute kennen oder so dazu
sage ich ja noch was zu selbstkritik so
was ich vielleicht nicht so cool findet
an einem eigenen kanal bzw wo ich mich
verbessern möchte und mehrmals okay also
erstmal danke schön für den ersten punkt
und dann zu mau aus ja ich kann euch nur
soviel sagen dass nach meinem abitur
jede mehr zeit für alles ist und
vielleicht werde ich dann auch öfters
mal bei luca rumhängen oder so und ihr
werdet supplied mit
ok jetzt werden alle so lieb ich ernte
ist echt ist schön das zu hören dass
leute so nett sind und so aber ich
dachte wir machen daraus mal so eine
echte kritik runde sowohl leute sagen
dass sie richtig nervt ich kann immer
sagen was mich nervt zum beispiel mich
stört dass mein content nicht so kreativ
ist wie er sein sollte in meinen augen
das liegt daran dass ich zu meinen teil
bin zum anderen teil relativ viel zu tun
hat für die schule
was ich aber auch nicht immer als
entschuldigung nehmen kann ich würde
nicht sagen dass meine videos nicht
sehenswert sind wir so was gottes wählen
sonst will ich nicht machen aber ich
finde meinen videos können echt noch
besser sein ich kann doch echt kreative
sachen machen und ja ich finde die
entwicklung di luca gemacht hat nicht
cool also der hatte ja sie einfach
gedacht ok hat sein abi hat da sein ding
gemacht mein abi bleibt für eine zeit
lang videos ausgesetzt und danach hat er
seine qualität krass verbessert und das
erhoffe ich mir auch dass ich das
durchsetzen kann und halt auch echt
eigene kreative sachen machen kann
soweit ich mir mehr zeit dafür nehmen
konzept erarbeite coolere kooperation
bzw
doch zusammenarbeiten mit anderen
youtuber machen kann und das hoffe ich
einfach darauf freue ich mich auf die
zeit nach meinem abi beziehungsweise ich
einfach generell mehr zeit habe dass ich
da investieren kann und mich verbessern
kann auch einfach was stetigkeit angeht
welche oft kommt er vor wirklich dass
ich einfach aussetzen so was liegt denn
ich denke das ok und was machst du jetzt
pvp sowieso was für ein spielmodus hast
du gestern also dann schon keine lust
drauf sonst was ich will einerseits mich
nicht zwingen videos zu machen
andererseits will ich aber auch gerne
videos machen einfach weil das
regelmäßige videos stärken so dass wir
die bindung sage ich mal so zwischen
youtuber community und so und deshalb
ist es halt irgendwie so ein kleiner
zwiespalt
ich setze auch öfter mal aus einfach
weil ich mit dem ok dass keine coole
idee für ein video
andererseits habe ich zwei tagen kein
videos gemacht und heute voll bock auf
videos und sowas hier ist ja auch
irgendwo kreativ zumindest habe ich
nicht schon dass ich mal gemacht
die qualität meiner face can überrascht
mich weil ich habe eigentlich dieselbe
facebook so weit ich weiß wie junge däne
und so luca kommt dann muss ich wohl
vielleicht mal mein programm
überarbeiten ich gucke nicht so oft in
meine videos rein wenn die fertig
gerendert sind daran könnte das
tatsächlich liegen ach so und wenn es
natürlich bei so was wie gap down ist
der computer einfach nicht mit dem 1000
farben wie zum beispiel von auf der l s
dem app oder sowas klar ich weiß nicht
ob das bei anderen videos besser ist als
ob ich dann falsch ränder oder so aber
ja also das wird glaube ich dadurch
verursacht
so wenig alkohol schon wieder so das
gibt es doch nicht
also ich hätte gerne so sachen gelesen
wie mich nervt das du also einfach so
vor kritik steht ihr okay das ist auch
schon wieder voll süß sie schreibt james
mich nervt nicht alles super
ein bild von ihm daumen und ihrem hund
das ist sehr süß so gucken immer hier
fixiere los fokussiere meine ich doch an
einem kanal
ich glaube was mich am meisten stört
wenn überhaupt dann erbt ist diese ganze
sache bei kaiser beste freund oder
jedenfalls so gut wie ich weiß ja nicht
wie das ist der gute freunde das ist
doch schön aber
okay das ist das was ich meinte dass es
das escort kritik das ist böse so was
heute einen kampf ich werde auf jeden
fall darauf achten dass der name nicht
ein kompetentes ist dass iris schäfer
nicht böse zu der dame sein könnte das
ist ein interessanter punkt also erst
mal dass das vielleicht interessant zu
wissen wie maut zu entstanden ist
logischerweise luca und ich hänge oft
miteinander rum du hast ja auch selbst
gesagt dass wir gute freunde sind sie
mir tatsächlich wir kennen uns schon
lange verstehen uns gut und so weiter
und so fort dann haben wir zusammen
rumgehangen zusammen videos gemacht und
die leute haben sich heute etwas
überlegt so beziehungsweise glauben
außer mir selbst überlegt aber wir
wurden halt so geschickt lustige
anekdote ich wusste zu dem zeitpunkt
nicht was schippen bedeutet das okay das
heißt so name für weit leute und da
haben wir haben jetzt halt so mautz
genannt und seine leute als cool
gefunden und logischerweise als youtuber
möchtest du sachen machen die leute cool
finden
insofern ist das zu sagen man macht es
nur für die klicks eigentlich einer
sätze richtig andererseits falsch
erstens meines youtuber man möchte
klickt das ist einfach so also klickt
geilheit ist eine sache aber
grundsätzlich will jeder geklickt werden
auf youtube weil dafür macht man es ja
klick geilheit ist wieder was anderes
und von clic geilheit würde ich dabei
nicht unbedingt sprechen weil für mich
ist miles sozusagen der name für die
freundschaft von mir und luca und leute
sehen halt gern das über freunde sind
und wir machen halt gerne faxen und wenn
wir also faxen machen dann kommen die
schippe und freundlich und so weiter und
so fort
aber es ist nicht so dass wir sagen so
da haben wir jetzt noch nicht voll da
müssen wir noch ein bisschen maut brian
buttern und so weiter und so fort
so ist das nicht also ist es eigentlich
mehr unsere freundschaft die wir teils
weil wir halt beide in öffentlichkeit
stehen öffentlich ausleben
das ist die sache ich hoffe es ist damit
beantwortet und ich bin ich zu sehr
abgeschafft das richtig eigentlich autos
heißt leute ich bin leider nicht schwul
ich habe eine freundin und blut bleibt
trotzdem wir immerhin mein er okay hier
eine frage von panik ob es okay dass ich
seinen namen sage dazu sollen wissen
dass kein geschichtlich wir reden findet
die beiden der aufnahme in die fans
cambridger guckst du dir gleich durch
die haare streicht ich war schon
manchmal okay wieder so eine kleinigkeit
ich fass mir oft in die haare
ich war es nicht das gehört irgendwie zu
youtube dazu bei mir ich hab mir schon
immer auf den jahre gefasst und ich kann
auch nicht aufhören
okay leute ich weiß nicht wie lange ist
jetzt insgesamt geworden ist ich fand's
auf jeden fall interessant auch mal
sowas zu machen
ich hätte mir teilweise okay es gibt
auch positive kritik klar aber ich hätte
mir mehr konstruktive vielleicht
negative kritik gewünscht wo ich darauf
eingehen kann
aber es war trotzdem cool ein paar
interessante sachen kam viele leute
waren sehr nett dankeschön dafür
und ja ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
schaut man alle leute die trotz allem
hinter mir stehen sage ich mal
obwohl ich echt oft unregelmäßig videos
und obwohl ich nicht so die 100%
kreativsten videos auf youtube macht
bleibt am ball und es wird sich lohnen
denke ich weil ich habe einige coole
sachen von macht's gut